- When I look through
the lens, I feel like I'm
in a whole new universe.
Having a camera, I don't
know, it makes me different
than other people, you know? (giggling)
Getting that picture,
it's like you can't fake
that expression, you
can't fake that emotion.
You know what I mean?
That's why I'm there.
I say you know what I mean way too much.
(uptempo music)
It's for the yearbook.
It's really hard studying for the SAT
because you have so many things to do.
You're not gonna get
better in one sitting.
You kinda have to be immersed in it.
You have to use that
experienced that you've gained
over and over and over.
Like you're able to spot the quality
in something that you do
when you care about it.
I'm usually like hey,
this is not good enough.
I need to get better just
purely out of my own desire
to do good, to do well.
I'll say it how I want to say it.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm joking.
(upbeat hip hop music)